nobody doesn't like this nobody I don't
want to live no more we got no water
idiot
that's the killer wonder Jesus crazy
[__] that [__]
[__] water for the guests bother it's
a little mule it's a little meal kick
sleep the little mule is alive and
kicking [__] you understand me we got
the little mule now and the big mule you
want to come to the Voodoo Lounge you
[__] with us you're [__] with the
wrong [__] you understand me
we got stars of death look at this we're
just gonna rip the [__] bag open what
do we got the two hundreds
[Music]
two three three apiece
open up a 600 which is nothing I got a
dog and everything I don't give a [__]
that all goes to the same filthy in the
salmon you waiting for is how we do it
[__]
little guys big guys here we go loser go
right here ladies and gentlemen what's
this
[Music]
go go go I guess they got no bongs and
Indonesians [__] when I'm [__] around
tonight we got wheat from the one I chew
and it's cousin is [__] that's a good
bond right then it's still got like
smoked little kill you we're not [__]
around on white don't you you want to do
pre-k reefer go somewhere else this is
high school refrain here Dawg you want
to do pre-k with your little [__]
buddies go ahead but if you up uncle
Joey's you got to show up late outlaw
Josie Wales throwing Heat you wait for
another one link well fine ain't no fire
the fire is in your soul you know I'm
saying this is it this is it
[__] it's Sunday night what
would Jesus do that's he gonna ask you
something if Jesus walked in those doors
we take a bonnet from the Mules cousin
yes he would
clean tip-top Magoo [__] hey you want
a brother Uncle Joe you better bring the
extra-long [__] oh it's all over don't
forget Thursday night the Ice House 830
working out with uncle Joey ten bucks I
got a notebook I bring it up then we
talked for an hour well that's it ten
bucks the week after that I'm in Long
Island with you [__] and a
[__] there you go the 23rd and 24th
suck my dick and call me shorty I was
born in 1940 lady ready for the meal
it's Sunday night oh [__] believe me
Nene I got enough to feed the need she
knows by the layers true [__] players
we think you're running was on a Sunday
night some [__] novice get your [__]
together this 60 minutes is over it's
time for uncle Joey now
[Music]
how you livin biggie smalls I'm saying
how you live it you sitting there if if
you're let's get this [__] it's you get
them at the store you get three in one
bag baby baby oh [__]
imagine them Benzes and it feels
stupendous [__] the dollar and a dream
[Music]
go back to school you're gonna play
cards you got to suck but for right now
you got uncle Joey little mice gasps
everything's gonna go away you wake up
Monday morning bubbles your whole
[__] mood ashame keep banging I love
it when you call me big what do you see
it's us against the world [__] biggie
smalls Junior MAFIA
[__] [__] dog if I'm you blow bubbles as
a kid he's back in town he wants your
number I've even cracked him funnies
listen Lee what's the story you're not
even stars you're not
[Music]
who's ready for fun biggie smalls the
[__] you thinking on these think I'm
gonna invite you out to play games in
there battleship here with some
1970-something what it's your type of
night [__] and if the ship goes
down we got a portable bombs
[__]
oh [__] if I'm in the United flight and
it goes into the Hudson box Ollie
kills a what
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's green beret type [__] if you want
money I drop the lately knows everybody
[Music]
what do you do you gonna sit there like
um it's bond timely you ready it's bleak
tip-top Magoo [__] what what
then we go [__] you wanted
actually you got action I don't show up
on a Friday night like the rest of the
amateurs Sunday
Scarface king of New York I want to be
what
[Music]
like a first to happy birthday [__] you
you clean this through it like you whack
off the little fun I'm giving you
instructions for free it's a shake your
parents are supposed to do what mama
surprise it that's the type of night of
this what
[Music]
[Laughter]
we'll go super setting it ready a super
set let's go Lee you got this let's go
eat Lee you got this
let's go me you don't touch it yet don't
touch it breathe out of your nose you
got this go ahead you got this I'm
talking about training training is the
key to everything you understand me you
can start small
[Music]
you gotta start small and then
commitment is little commitments become
small commitments two weeks ago Lee
couldn't do the savage now he's doing
the meals cousin you understand me you
know why he's stuck with it that's what
it's all about life you keep showing up
but I keep showing up you gotta keep
showing up that you know how bad all
three of us work comedy when we started
bad okay
people boo is throw [__] at you but you
gotta keep showing up that's the [__]
lesson for the week got something you
keep showing up to you become a [__]
headache people they won't really get
rid of this fat [__] but one day
you turn the tank
you turn the [__] light on them and
you become good at what you do just like
that cuz some people takes 90 days some
people takes nine years me you know I'm
[__] takes nine [__] years but I
kept showing up [__] get your
[__] together youtube.com / c / Joey
Diaz ten minutes we'll be ready Iraq all
right
stay black don't tell on my [__]
century